RAJIV SATYAL: I'm
Indian, just Indian.
I'm not South Asian any more
than Russians are North Asian.
I'm not Asian Indian
or East Indian.
There are 1.3 billion of us.
We don't need a
cardinal direction, OK?
It's not our fault that
Christopher Columbus got lost.
Sure, we love our states, but
there's strength in numbers.
One out of every six
human beings is Indian,
so stop dividing us.
The British already
did that once.
And we need to quit saying
that we're not Indian
because I wasn't born here, or
sound like this, or eat that.
Our hearts are Indian.
We are feelers.
We gave the world the
romance of Bollywood films
and the music of Ravi
Shankar and Zubin Mehta
and Lata Mangeshkar
and Asha Bhosle
and the allure of
the "Kama Sutra."
We are thinkers.
We are great at math
because we invented numbers.
And we're pretty
good at letters too.
We are doctors and
engineers and techies.
And we mean business.
We're the world's third largest
economy and the wealthiest
ethnic group in America.
We are huge and efficient.
India is all on one time zone.
That way, everybody
in the country
is still late, but
at the same time.
We never invade anyone because
we already have everything.
Chess, the ruler, the button,
wireless communication,
arranged marriage flush
toilets, steel, democracy-- all
us, all India.
And you are welcome,
world, for yoga,
and elevating cricket into
a multibillion-dollar sport,
and making food so good that
you sailed across the planet
to come have some.
Our food is hot.
Our country is hot.
Our women are hot.
Our men are-- lucky.
Where the world
prays, we meditate.
We practically invented
religious tolerance.
And we gave you Mahatma
Gandhi and pundits and gurus
and karma and dharma and
kismet and reincarnation.
The motherland is
magical and mystical.
And no matter who you are,
you can find yourself here,
in incredible India.
[SPEAKING HINDI]-- I am Indian.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
And I'm late.
Told you I was Indian.
It's an honor to
be here at Google.
I actually got a degree
in materials engineering.
That was the big thing.
That's how I prepped for
comedy, I got a degree
in materials engineering.
I was going to
work in wafer fab.
I was going to be
a wafer fabrication
engineer in the Silicon Valley.
And until today,
February 19, 2016,
I have disappointed my parents.
But today, I'm working
in the Silicon Valley.
So here I am.
So I guess, finally,
my parents can be proud
that I'm actually here in
the Silicon Valley with you
like a good Indian.
It's a lot of
Indians here today,
which is mostly--
token white guy.
OK.
Right, in the front row--
it's still your country,
don't worry.
That's great.
It still works out, so
no problem with that.
No need to take
the country back.
OK.
I'm actually giving TED X
talk in a couple of weeks.
And so people have been asking
me-- friends, they're saying,
oh, you're speaking at Google.
You're giving a talk at Google.
Are you practicing?
You don't come to
Google to practice.
This is the Super Bowl, OK.
So this is the highlight
of my year so far,
but it's only, what, 50
days old, so not a problem.
But I'm here to give a
speech and break down
that video that you saw.
How many people, by round of
applause, have seen that video?
How many people have seen it?
OK.
You can clap.
It's OK.
Let's get some
energy going in here.
It's Friday.
How many people have not seen
it, by round of applause?
I guess it's a weird
thing to applaud for.
But yeah, that's fine.
I'm glad that if
we hadn't seen it,
we wish we wouldn't
have seen it.
But no, I'm glad that a
lot of you had seen it.
Some of you hadn't.
So that's very cool.
But I'm going to explain,
I think, to some extent,
why that video worked, and also
tell you a little about humor,
about stand-up, about jokes.
And I want to make
it interactive.
So if you have questions or if
you are bored-- well, if you're
bored, just leave, I guess.
But if you have
questions, just feel
free to put your hand up
or shout something out.
I think that's always a
good thing to be able to do.
It's odd, though, to talk
about why something worked
as a stand-up comedian,
because normally, we
talk about our failures.
We don't really talk
about our successes,
because failure is funny.
You know I mean?
It's funny to watch
somebody fail.
That's why we have fail
blogs and hashtag fail
and everything.
It's a lot funnier.
If I just get up
here and tell you,
and that's how I got the
girl back to my apartment
and I hooked up with
her, OK, [INAUDIBLE].
That's not really a funny story,
that's just somebody bragging.
I do want to talk about jokes.
I do live in the Valley.
And I don't know how many
people saw "Clueless."
This movie's now 20 years old,
which is crazy for me to think.
Somebody's nodding back there.
OK, good.
So-- which is why, up here, I
have to speak like an adult,
because I live in the Valley.
Normally we tend to go up
at the end of our sentences.
We all kind of talk
like this down in LA.
And I know, in San
Francisco, you don't like LA.
So as long as I
make fun of LA, I
think I'm going
to do pretty well.
But I realize that some of
my friends, they're cool.
I'm not a cool guy.
I've never been a cool guy.
Some of my friends, they'll
develop cool phrases.
They'll say, yeah,
let's all turn up, yo.
Let's all turn up.
That's a good look.
I want to talk like that,
but it just doesn't come out
of my mouth like that.
I always pick up the
annoying phrases.
I think she's already leaving.
OK, fine.
But I always pick them up.
Because a friend of
mine in the Valley,
she always says, "right."
She's one of these
women who always
says "right" at the
end of her sentences.
Or whenever somebody gets
finished speaking, she'll go,
"anyway," which is
such a beautifully
condescending way of speaking.
It's so great.
I mean, somebody
will say, "and that's
why I'm voting for
Donald Trump"-- "anyway."
It's just such a
great thing to say.
It's amazing.
But I noticed I had to stop
saying the word "like."
I was saying "like" constantly.
And I realized I
had a problem when
I said it three times in a row.
OK?
So I actually said, "Like
like like?" as a question.
And some of you understand
that, which is sad.
We have a problem-- it's an
epidemic in this country--
of likes, too many likes.
And I think I'm not at Facebook,
so I should stop saying "like."
But the point being-- I think
you can like things on YouTube
too, right?
But I realized this.
Actually, on our way
here, we were driving
and I saw a guy hitchhiking.
I thought he was
giving me a like.
So it was one of those things.
So it does actually
happen, I guess, here.
But no, a friend
of mine was trying
to ascertain whether I was
fond of a certain girl.
And so to distinguish between
liking her as a friend
and like liking her as
someone more than a friend,
I said to him-- I asked the
question-- "Like like like?"
That's when I realized
I have a problem.
Ouch.
You don't want to say "like
like like" three times in a row.
Anyway, the point being,
that I'm going to talk about
jokes and where you might
find them in society.
They appear in different places
and they're more ubiquitous
than you might imagine.
There's a dollar word for you.
You can right-click that one.
So I'm going to break down
humor, stand-up, jokes,
and lessons from I am Indian.
Let's see how far I get.
I have a lot of
content here, but I'm
going to treat this
like my dates--
I'm just going to see
how far I can get.
That's supposed be a joke.
All right, so let's
start with humor.
The job of a comedian
is to make people laugh.
It is the simplest
job in society.
It's not the easiest,
but it's the simplest.
It's just three words.
If you also want to say
something else, that's great.
There are comedians
who say funny things
and there are comedians
who say things funny.
And they are sort of
two different things
if you have to explain
why a comedian is funny.
We showed a little clip of
Russell there inadvertently.
But sometimes you may
say, why is he funny.
Ah, I don't know.
He's just funny.
The way he is, he's just funny.
But what does it mean?
So we've got to break
that down a little bit.
I don't remember if
it was Chris Rock or I
who said this-- I get us mixed
up all the time-- but it was
really-- the goal was to
make people laugh in the room
and think on the way home.
That was really the thing.
You don't want people to
think while you're here.
Otherwise-- there's no
sound to thinking, right?
So I want you to laugh in the
room and think on the way home.
That's always a
big thing for us.
And so not all
comedians are what we
would call social commentators.
Some people are just
there to get a laugh
and other people want to say
something more than something
funny.
If we go back to
medieval times, there
was something called
a court jester.
Round of applause--
how many people
have heard of a court jester?
How many people have at
least heard of this concept?
OK, that's good.
You can clap, that's
fine-- or raise your hand.
Either one is OK.
Does anyone know the
role of the court jester?
Does anyone know what the
purpose of the court jester
was?
Yes.
Yes, perfect, to point out
the absurdities of society,
of what's going on around them.
Also, it was to convey
messages to the king
without fear of being beheaded--
that was a big thing--
without fear of retribution.
That was a really important
message or thing for him
to be able to do, to convey
messages to the king.
Today, we have multiple kings.
We've got the president, sure.
The president can
be sort of a king.
But we also have the media.
We have the pope-- unless,
again, you're Donald Trump.
He's going to be a
consistent punch line for me,
I think, this time-- the pope.
We have corporate America
and all of these things
that do exist.
But one by one, through
one scandal or another,
it seems like we've
lost our kings.
If you go all the way back to
Richard Nixon and Watergate
and the Vietnam
War, the government
lost a lot of credibility
here in this country.
And I have to-- in America.
We have so many Indians here.
I need to make sure
that we say in America.
The government here lost
a lot of credibility.
Brian Williams, right?
He lost his job for lying.
And there was a
joke going around
that he had-- he was
joking about the--
or he was actually talking about
being involved with the Iraq
War and is the only person
who lost his job from lying
about the Iraq War.
Right?
So that was a joke
that was going around--
it was kind of unfair--
that he sort of exaggerated
a little bit, he lost his job.
And so the media
has-- especially
with the rise of talk radio, Fox
News, the liberal media, nobody
really knows where to
get facts from anymore.
I don't know how many people
saw the movie "Spotlight."
I'd ask you to clap,
but it's not really
the kind of movie you clap for.
But it pointed out the scandals
in the Catholic church.
And so the churches have
lost a lot of credibility.
We look at violent
extremism with Islam
and things like that.
That's not to impugn a religion,
but people now are very scared
to talk about religion.
Whether it's Catholicism,
Islam, Hinduism, Christianity,
anything, people are on edge.
And it's lost some
credibility as well.
In 2008, we had the
financial crisis, right?
By round of applause,
how many people
were in the country in 2008?
How many people
were here in 2008?
OK, so quite a few
people were here.
And anyone here, were
you working at Google?
Anyone still here at Google?
OK, so few of us were--
not us, but today I'm
working at Google.
So not getting paid, but
whatever, that's not the point.
We're not keeping track.
No one's bitter.
The point is that in 2008,
the economy fell apart
and people lost
faith in capitalism,
in the mores of society, and
what this country is built on.
And it's kind of funny, because
I was pre-med for a while.
I was, like I said, an engineer.
But I was pre-med.
Now I'm post-med.
I just skipped the med
party, really, altogether.
That's where the work
was, so I did that.
And that was back in '94.
I'm going to turn 40 soon, so
I'm a little older than-- well,
maybe I'm younger
than you thought.
Who knows?
I don't know.
My parents really wanted
me to be a doctor.
After that, I decided
to get out of that.
And the Clintons
sort of tinkered
with the health care system.
Doctors were not
making as much money.
And so I that's when
I went into the wafer
fab and semiconductors
and P-N junctions
and I was going to do that.
And then the dot com
bust happened in 2000.
That was my senior
year in college.
And that fell apart.
And then I decided, you
know what, maybe I'll
go into finance.
And then in 2008, that
whole thing fell apart.
So suddenly, becoming a
comedian did not look so risky.
My parents said, go
ahead, be comedian.
It's fine.
So all of a sudden, it
was not such a bad idea
at this point in time to
just go ahead with that.
And so after all the
kings have been slain,
maybe the jester is
the last one standing.
I went to a friend of
mine's to get the picture,
so that was at least good.
But you can see that I'm a
jester in that, as a comedian,
but I've stolen a king's
crown so to speak.
Many, many people
make arguments, right?
After all, stand-up
comedy, a lot of the time,
is really just kind
of a funny argument.
We're trying to get you
to see our point of view.
But lots of people
make arguments, right?
We've got the president--
you're going to see Obama a lot
in this presentation as
well-- Obama as the president.
We have preachers who make
arguments all the time
or make, of course, sermons.
Columnists, when they
write anything you read,
it tends to be an
argument to get you over
to that point of view.
And then you have CEOs who,
of course, get up there
and try to get people to
invest in the company.
And I love the profile.
I don't know who
wrote it, but "This
is most famous CEO of World."
So he's not just
the CEO of Google,
he's the CEO of the world.
OK?
So I didn't know if you
knew earth has a CEO.
But I think as we
discover more planets,
we need to promote somebody.
And we thought, Google Earth,
Google Maps, maybe this guy
will be the one.
So "This 43 years old
man is Google's CEO."
So he's been demoted in his
own bio, I guess, evidently.
"His full name is
Pichai Sundara--"
words of South Indians.
Who can read this?
AUDIENCE: Sundararajan.
RAJIV SATYAL: Sundararajan,
OK, thank you,
with an American
accent at that, too.
You really showed me up--
born in Tamil Nadu in India.
Which, I love how it puts it
in parentheses in case you
didn't know were Tamil Nadu is,
but maybe some people don't.
But now it's kind of
old news that people
are getting their news not
just from traditional media.
We're getting it from
"The Daily Show."
People will tell you
that they don't just
go to watch Trevor Noah or John
Oliver or Dennis Miller or Bill
Maher for jokes.
A lot of the shows are--
they're kind of serious.
I mean, there are laughs, sure.
But a lot of times,
it's serious.
So we're getting that and
we're seeing that people are
getting their news that way.
If you doubt the
power of a joke--
some of you will know this
man and some of you won't.
His name is Hannibal Buress.
And Hannibal Buress
is the one who
told the joke about Bill Cosby,
which led to Bill Cosby's
now being indicted.
And he is going to go to court.
Hannibal Buress.
He made a joke.
And in fact, several
women had come forth
to talk about Bill Cosby.
Their concerns were not
taken seriously, which
is a horrible thing in society.
And it took a stand-up
comic-- and some people
point out, a black man stand-up
comic-- to say and make
the joke about Bill Cosby.
And he even said,
well Bill Cosby, yeah,
but you raped women.
And he said this in a stand-up
act and it got laughs,
but it led to the
investigation of Bill Cosby.
This was a joke that
revealed the truth
and really kind
of a scary thing.
But I think that's what's really
great about stand-up comedy
is nobody is bigger
than the field.
No matter how big a
stand-up comic gets,
the person is still
a subset of humor.
Right?
If you look at Michael Jordan,
he transcended basketball.
He was bigger than basketball.
There were people in
Africa, there are certainly
people in India, there are
certainly people in Australia
that didn't follow the NBA.
They didn't really
follow the Chicago Bulls.
But almost everybody knew
who Michael Jordan was.
Barack Obama-- again, somebody
who transcended politics
talking about hope and change.
But nobody transcends humor.
And I think that
was sort of what's
great about stand-up comedy is
we use it to expose the truth.
And that's the
idea, even if it's
about other stand-up comedians.
And in that case, Hannibal
Buress doing a joke about Bill
Cosby, we even eat our own.
I think that's a good
thing, which is probably
why his name is Hannibal.
I worked hard on
that slide, so I need
you to probably laugh harder.
But anyway, the
point is that-- no.
Recently-- and you'll appreciate
this-- Facebook board member
Marc Andreessen, he tweeted.
I'm sure a lot of people in this
room have followed this story.
His tweet, again, Donald
Trump-like in nature.
It got more and more out
of control until he finally
tweeted "Anti-colonialism has
been economically catastrophic
for the Indian
people for decades.
Why stop now?"
That was supposed to be a joke.
And you hear how
hard you're laughing?
Yeah, right, not at all.
Nobody was laughing on Twitter.
Nobody was laughing about this
joke that apparently was made.
But it revealed--
a lot of people
think-- Facebook's intentions,
or a lot of companies
intentions, to go and have this
colonial approach to what they
still see as a
third world country.
And so that was a joke that was
not funny, but a lot of people
think it revealed the truth.
So there should be no doubt that
jokes are very, very powerful
and they can work to our
benefit or to our detriment.
Some good examples-- a
lot of people, I'm sure,
know Tina Fey.
She and Amy Poehler hosted
the Golden Globes in 2015,
which they've done a few times.
One of her best jokes
was when George Clooney
was in the audience and he had
his wife Amal there with him.
And Tina Fey clowned him
by saying, "Amal, his wife,
is a human rights lawyer who
worked on the Enron case,
was an advisor to Kofi
Annan regarding Syria,
and was selected for
a three-person UN
commission investigating rules
of war violations in the Gaza
Strip.
So tonight, her husband is
getting a Lifetime Achievement
Award."
Right?
So exactly, it was a
really, really funny moment.
And it really kind of
threw men under the bus.
It threw actors under the bus.
What are we
worshipping in society
that she is so accomplished?
What does a person have
to do to get recognition?
And George Clooney is the one
getting all the good looks
there.
So that was a great example.
There's something called the
White House correspondents'
dinner that happens every year.
And Stephen Colbert,
in 2006, roasted
George W. Bush by saying,
"Now I know that there
are some polls out there
saying that this man--"
and he points to
George W. Bush--
"has a 32% approval rating.
But guys like us, we don't
pay attention to the polls.
We know that polls are a
collection of statistics that
reflect what people are thinking
'in reality.' And reality,
as we all know, has a
well-known liberal bias."
Right?
So it really roasted
George W. Bush and said,
you know what, we're
going to point out
something that's true that
you may not be acknowledging.
Still one of my favorites
and my favorite comedian
of all time, Chris
Rock, a great example
when he said, "You don't
need no gun control.
You know what you need?
We need some bullet control.
We need to control the bullets.
That's right.
I think all bullets should
cost $5000, $5000 for a bullet.
You know why?
'Cause if a bullet
cost $5000, there
would be no more
innocent bystanders."
Right?
And so he does this whole
bit about how people
would be a lot more careful.
They would shoot somebody
to take the bullet back,
because it was still
their property.
So it was a really good
example of a problem.
A lot of people watched that and
they went, yeah, why don't we
do that.
That's actually a
really good solution.
That was in 1999.
Then if you go all
the way back to 1989,
I don't know how many
people saw the movie
"When Harry Met Sally."
This is Billy Crystal
from that movie.
We couldn't use the
image from the movie
because all these
images are approved.
We did the right thing.
We did not go after
copyrighted images.
So we had to get one when
he's-- too old to sue us?
I don't know what it is really.
If you remember the-- I'll
get sued for that though.
But there's a point in
"When Harry Met Sally"
when he's talking, when
Harry is talking to Sally.
And he just says--
they're walking
along the streets in New York.
And he says, "Really, but
what's so hard about finding
an apartment?
What you do is you look
in the obituary section.
You see who died, find
out where they lived,
and tip the doorman.
What they could do to make
it easier is combine the two.
You know, Mr. Klein
died yesterday
leaving behind a
wife, two children,
and a spacious
three-bedroom apartment
with a wood burning fireplace."
So we watch that
and go, yeah, they
should do that, especially
here in San Francisco.
You could really use that,
I think, in the Bay Area.
With prices going
out of control,
maybe this would be
a good thing to have.
So it's examples of
comedians telling
jokes but revealing
solutions, revealing truths,
and things that are
a little bit deeper.
This phenomenon of
using humor and truth
is not surprising, because
they're very closely related.
Mary Poppins-- and
no presentation
is complete by a
nearly 40-year-old man
without using Mary Poppins
in it-- Mary Poppins once
sang a song that said
a spoonful of sugar
helps the medicine go down.
And I think that
medicine is truth
and the sugar is the humor.
So in every speech, you
try to think about what
your bumper sticker would be.
So that would be
my bumper sticker,
"Humor is the spoonful
of sugar that helps
the medicine of truth go down."
I hope you don't drive a
Prius, it's not going to fit.
So I was trying to get it down
a little bit shorter than that
as short as I am, but
it didn't really happen.
But I think that's sort
of the thrust of my speech
overall in the idea
that we can use humor
to get across the truth.
And again, this
is not a new idea.
Dick Clark, in 1959, he
said, "Humor is always
based on the modicum of truth.
Have you ever heard a joke
about a father-in-law?"
Right?
So he's starting to get
across the idea of that.
You go back to 1884
with Nietzsche even
saying, "We should
call every truth false
which is not accompanied
by at least one laugh."
And we can go 500 years before
that to Geoffrey Chaucer.
And he wrote, "Many a true
word is spoken in jest."
So using humor to convey
truth makes a lot of sense.
In fact, a lot of businesses--
it's not really a-- well,
I guess politics is a
business, but we just
like this picture, four living
presidents at the time-- a lot
of businesses are
using comedians now.
They're using improvisers, using
writers to warm up the audience
or get people to
brainstorm and play games
and all that sort of thing.
And it's great.
It's a great idea.
But we're also using
stand-up comedians.
And stand-up comedians
are a little bit different
because we're actually
saying something.
I'm not saying that improvisers
and writers are not trying to,
but-- wait, no, that is
completely what I'm saying.
Stand-up comedians are better
than improvisers and writers
because we actually have to
come up with it in advance.
Improv is sort of
impressive that they came up
with anything.
But stand-up comedy sometimes,
if it's just a blank room,
they're just looking
at you going,
you've had six months
to come up with this
and this is what
you're telling us.
So it's a level of
expectations game.
So I actually have
a business where
we hire stand-up comedians
to help marketers generate
insights for their brands.
No big deal, it's just
really, really successful.
It doesn't matter.
The point is that we actually
had a comedian come in--
not Jerry Seinfeld.
But Jerry Seinfeld made a
movie called "Comedian."
And if you're interested
in this sort of topic--
I see some of you
nodding-- this movie
was really something else.
Because it's a documentary.
And the tagline for it is
"Where does comedy come from?"
Did you see it?
Yeah, really great movie.
Where does comedy come from?
So he's the main
character in it,
because he made
it, just like I'm
the main character
in my own speech.
That'd be weird if I weren't.
But there's one
other comedian in it
and his name is Orny Adams.
We had Orny Adams
fly out to a company.
I'm going to tell
you which company,
keep that part confidential.
But there was a part where the
underlings at the company-- I
don't think they went by
those titles-- they wanted
to convey to the king, to the
GM that they were not really
big fans of the name of
one of their products.
They had changed the name.
And so we had Orny
Adams go on stage
and just clown this brand.
He just gets up
there and he goes,
you took something that I
understood, like Greek yogurt,
and you changed it to Oikos.
What the hell is Oikos?
And you could see the
whole place go nuts.
And you could see
the GM nod his head.
And we got the idea
across to the king.
We used a stand-up comedian
to get the truth across,
because everyone
underneath the GM
was a little bit
scared to convey that,
so a real life example
of how that can work.
I wanted to ask, do you think
stand-up comedy is hard?
Do you think it's hard or easy?
AUDIENCE: Hard.
RAJIV SATYAL: Hard.
Does anyone think it's easy?
OK.
You can't say that, because
otherwise I'll have you come up
and do it.
So it's sort of a mixed matter,
a stacked deck, I guess.
I'll tell you why it is.
The whole idea with
talks at Google
is to break things down, right?
So let me tell you
why it's difficult.
First of all, you can see
us do it while we do it.
That's odd.
I could ask anyone here,
are you good at your job.
I could say, are you
good at your job.
You're going to say yes, right?
Because I'm not going
to see you do it.
So I'm going to go to
assume you're good, right?
You can tell me all day long.
And you have multiple chances.
If you mess up on your
spreadsheet or whatever,
you could just fix it.
But I can't do that.
You're going to see me do it.
I can't speak up
here and then try
to talk to someone
after the show and say,
I'm this really amazing comic.
We just saw you eat
it for 45 minutes.
You suck.
Right?
So you can see it happen.
This is why I don't
understand doctors.
And maybe I'm just bitter
because, like I said,
I'm post-med.
But I don't know
what doctors do.
I don't know what
their job is, still.
It's just totally--
we're staying
with a couple of friends
who-- my friend [INAUDIBLE]
is a doctor.
He's an ophthalmologist.
And I just don't really
get what his job is, OK?
I go to the doctor.
And first of all,
you see the nurse.
The nurse does 90%
of the doctor's job.
OK?
Right?
You see the nurse first.
The nurse does blood
pressure, weight.
Most of the stuff,
you spend most
of the time with the nurse.
I don't if we have any people
who were nurses or are.
Any Malayalis?
OK.
They're always nurses.
It's true.
I'm glad you laughed.
Sometimes people grown.
Like, it's not bad,
I'm just saying.
You know?
But I don't know if they're
nurses or registered nurses.
The only people in
society-- I don't
understand a registered nurse.
I don't get that.
They're the only people in
society who are registered.
Where's this registry?
I don't get it.
Them and sex offenders, they're
the only people who registered,
I guess.
You can grown on that one.
So the point is that the
nurse does 90% of it.
Then the doctor comes in.
And I've never
had an appointment
with a doctor that lasts
more than two minutes.
OK?
It's like a lot of things
in my life, I guess.
But it's two minutes long.
And it's never a
consecutive 120 seconds.
The doctor keeps
leaving the room.
The person, he keeps getting up.
I don't know, is
he-- what's he doing?
Does he not know the answer?
Or is he looking up
stuff on the Web MD?
Or is he-- I don't know what.
Is he googling it?
I don't know what he's doing.
What's he doing?
And then it's his
turn to headline.
It's his turn to
perform, to do surgery.
That's the hardest
part of a doctor's job.
And then they knock us out.
We don't even get to
see them do it, right?
They can mess up, whatever.
And they don't even do it.
An anesthesiologist does that.
They don't even do that.
Then they prescribe a pill and
a pharmacist gives you the pill.
So I don't know
what a doctor does.
They're general contractors, OK?
I don't think they
have a job, really.
I think that they gather a
bunch of people in a room.
They're general contractors.
That's their job.
That's the difference there.
The second thing what's
difficult about stand-up
is we come up with this
whole thing ourselves.
Right?
I have no one to blame up here.
I can't say, well,
Tonby, you wrote it.
No, obviously, I wrote it, I
directed it, I produced it,
I edited it.
So I get the credit or
the blame depending.
Right?
So that's pretty great.
Although you get credit for
turnout, so nice job on the.
Yeah, good work on that.
That's really impressive.
The other weird thing
about stand-up comedy
is you don't know the genre.
This is really weird.
If you ever hear someone go,
let's go to a stand-up comedy
club, maybe you are
specifically going
to see Russell
Peters, or Chris Rock,
or Dave Chapelle,
or Jerry Seinfeld.
But a lot of the
time, people aren't.
They just go to a comedy club.
And you have no idea.
If you go to a concert,
it's different, right?
You know if it's hip hop,
or classical, or country,
or if it's EDM.
You know specifically
what it is.
But that's not
true for stand-up.
Same thing with movies, you
want to go to the movies.
Right?
And it's a big thing.
Is that a comedy?
Is it a drama?
Is it an action?
You get up in the stand-up
comic, he could be clean,
could be dirty, could be
sarcastic, could be ironic,
could be slapstick.
All these different
things, you have no clue.
So the audience usually has no
idea what you're about to do.
A lot of my friends
in LA are actors.
We shot this.
I was very proud of it.
Rajiv, left to his own
devices-- I'm on my phone.
It's brilliant.
Anyway, the point being that
a lot of my friends in LA
are actors.
And it's almost funny,
because it's very popular
to say that I'm great at drama.
I'm a great dramatic
actor or actress,
but I'm really bad at comedy.
And to me, it always
sounds like a cop-out.
Because drama, there's
no measurement.
Right?
In comedy, there are metrics.
You can count the laughs.
So I think that's
what's different
about it is if you don't get
laughs, then it wasn't funny.
Right?
And that's true even
with going to a concert.
Like I'm saying, if you
go to a jazz concert--
I don't know how many people
have been to a jazz concert,
right-- no one knows
what's going on.
You don't know if
it's good or bad.
You just try to
act like you know.
It's like drinking wine
up here in wine country.
It's good, so good.
I don't know.
I have no concept.
No one knows.
No one knows if it's
good, but you have to act.
It's like the
emperor's new clothes.
That's how the kings are
getting slain, I guess.
But it's true.
And a lot of people have walked
out of a jazz concert and gone,
I guess that guy was good.
I mean, yeah, people
were clapping.
But no one's ever walked
out of a comedy show
and gone, that guy was
hilarious, but I didn't laugh.
Right?
No one has ever
done that, right?
If you laughed, it's funny.
If you didn't, it's not.
We have to watch what we say.
This man, Michael Richards,
known as Kramer-- some of you
are nodding and laughing
and maybe groaning--
but he got in trouble
at the Laugh Factory.
I was actually on that
stage on a Tuesday
and this happened on a Friday,
three days after I performed.
Hopefully I didn't jinx the
stage or anything like that.
But he got up there and he said
some really, really horrible,
racist stuff.
And that was the
end of his career.
And so I think what's
really scary for us
is, anything we say,
especially with society
being really touchy
as it's gotten,
it's not just that I
could walk the room,
I could tell a really bad joke,
and you could all just leave.
But in this day
and age-- and this
is on YouTube and all
those sorts of things
being taped for YouTube--
you can lose your career.
It could be over.
If you say something really,
really awful that people
just kind of get
horribly offended by,
you can lose your career.
So that's another
reason it's scary.
And finally, a
lot of people love
to ask, do you practice
in front of a mirror.
It's a question I
get all the time.
People go, do you practice
in front of the mirror.
And no, I don't.
I don't practice in
front of a mirror,
because practicing in front
of a mirror is like walking.
It's easy to do.
Anybody could just walk
on the sidewalk, right?
Well, not anyone-- there
are some people that can't.
But a lot of people can, OK?
Babies-- that's what
I was going to say.
But if you look at public
speaking, we've all done this.
We all have to speak
publicly, right?
And you ran it at home
and it went so well.
You ran it in the car.
You had a joke or you had
something you were going to do.
And then you tell it to
people and nothing, right,
just nothing.
And you go, what happened.
It's because when you
get in front of people,
it's like you're on
a balancing beam.
The audience is the height.
All of a sudden,
there's a consequence.
You ever think that?
You see a ledge, you go,
well, if the ledge were
on the ground, I could walk it.
You can walk on a straight line.
But it's very hard to walk
if it's up in the air.
Why?
Because there's consequences.
You could fall.
You could hurt yourself.
And if that's public
speaking, then stand-up comedy
is walking a tight rope.
OK?
It is a completely
different game,
because this is dangerous.
This looks really scary.
I don't know if this person has
a net under him or her or not,
but this looks really scary.
And what's hard about this also,
there are outside elements.
OK?
So the outside elements
and whether this person
is going to do this, you've
got the rope element as well.
With a balance beam,
right, you're in one place.
It's not going to move.
You may move.
This, you're moving
and the balance beam
slash rope is moving.
So that's the element of timing.
And that's what's so difficult.
So practicing in front
of a mirror does nothing.
The audience is going to laugh.
It's you.
You can laugh and see
the audience laugh.
It's a mirror, right?
So it's not really
that hard to do.
I think I do want to talk
a little bit about jokes.
At their core, jokes
are one, two, four.
That's what a joke is at
it's most basic, meaning
that when you saw
me going one, two,
you thought maybe I was going
to say three and I said four.
You can now look at
it and go, oh, you
we're doubling the numbers.
That's what you were doing.
And that's what
a joke is, right?
After the person
tells the punch line,
you go, oh yeah, OK, I should've
been able to figure that out.
Right?
So you kind feel, oh
yeah, that's right.
And so it's the
element of surprise.
It's not one, two, three
or one, two, seven.
OK?
So I had a friend of
mine explain it to me.
He goes, oh, jokes
are A, B, G. I go,
no, that doesn't make any sense.
One, two, seven isn't a thing.
One, two, three-- if I got up
here and said one, two, three,
you'd all look at
me and go, yeah, so.
We can count, dude.
I mean, what, we came
here out of our time,
took time out of our
schedule to watch you count?
So basically, the idea is
that jokes are one, two, four.
Every joke actually contains
a setup and a punch line.
You go from point A to point
B. And there's actually
a comedy club here
in San Francisco
and it's called The Punch Line.
I don't know how many
people have actually
been to The Punch Line.
OK, from your nods,
some of the people
have been to The Punch Line.
Actually, I perform there.
I do really well
at The Punch Line,
but I think I could do a
lot better at a club called
the Setup.
You know what I mean?
If all I had to do
was just set up jokes,
I would be way better.
It's way easier to find
setups than punch lines.
I don't know how many people
have been to a 3D movie.
By round of applause, how many
people have been to a 3D movie?
You know how they
give you the glasses,
the red and blue glasses, in
the beginning of the film?
Have you ever done
this thing where,
in the middle of the movie,
maybe you take the glasses off
your face just to see
what the screen looks
like without the glasses?
Yeah, it's weird.
You ever drive along in your car
and look down at your odometer?
And maybe it's 9,993
or 9,994, maybe 1,999.
You're getting very, very close.
And you think, oh
my gosh, I'm going
to see it turn 10,000
or 100,000 on this.
I'm going to see it turn.
Then maybe go through a
drive-through or a Starbucks
or something and you look
down and it's, like, 10,003
and you go, oh, I missed it.
Anyway, I've got
about 20 of those
that I'm not going
to subject you to.
But it is very, very easy, I
think, in life, to find setups.
It's much, much harder
to find punch lines.
One, two is the setup.
And I believe there
were five reasons why
I am Indian worked, why it
was shared by Bollywood stars,
why it was played in front
of Narendra Modi, why
it was seen 50 million times.
Why is that?
And it's only
500,000 on YouTube,
but if someone here
can jack that up,
that would help me a little bit.
So if you can just play
with those numbers,
that's why I really came here.
But no, it got shared
a lot on Facebook
and it got shared
a lot on WhatsApp.
I think, especially in India,
it got shared on WhatsApp a lot.
That was really the thing.
I didn't even know a video
could go viral on WhatsApp.
I wasn't even aware
of that phenomenon.
But that's kind
of what happened.
So I think what's
important for anyone,
if you're trying to
communicate a message-- so how
does this now become
useful to some extent
once you know about
humor and stand-up
and jokes-- when you're
trying to convey a message,
whether it's an email, whether
it's a commercial, whether it's
a product launch,
whether it's anything,
I think there are principles
that we could all use.
And of course, I'm going to
say humor as the number one
since I'm a comedian.
But how do we find a setup?
When I said jokes are one, two,
four-- for some of you just
joining us, I said jokes are
one, two, four-- one, two
is the setup.
Right?
And people always ask, how
do you find these setups?
Where do you find them?
How do you do that?
Well, that's the same
thing as asking a comedian,
where do you get
your material from.
It's the exact same question
and it's a really good question.
We don't look for what's funny.
I think that's a big misnomer.
I think a lot of
people think that we
walk around looking
with a pad and a pen
and trying to note down
behavior that we think is funny.
That could not be
further from the truth.
We look for things
that are incongruent.
We look for incongruity,
or incongruence,
or whatever the word is.
I don't know what the noun is.
It doesn't matter,
you don't need
to know that stuff for this job.
It only deals in language,
why would I know that?
But we deal in incongruity.
We look for what's different.
So if you looked at this
grid of black and white,
we'll all go to the pink one.
We'll all go to the
red dot, and that's
just because we're Indian.
But we'll all go to that and--
it's a bindi or a tilaka.
But no, the idea is
we're looking at this
and all our eyes go there.
Right?
Why?
Because it's different.
And you look at it and you
go, hmm, that looks funny.
Right?
Just like when somebody asks
you and you're not feeling well,
you might say, I feel funny.
What you mean is you feel
different from how you usually
feel.
And so we sort of
play around with that.
That's a big thing.
What a lot of marketers
will call that is a way in.
A lot of times you have to make
a commercial or reach somebody.
How are you going to find this
consumer when and where she's
receptive?
And I worked at Procter and
Gamble for years at P and G,
punjabis and gujaratis.
And I worked there
for a long time.
Actually, well, now is as good
a time as any to tell you this.
I'm Punjabi.
That's my wife
sitting right there.
So we just got married
six months ago.
She's gujaratis.
So yeah, thank you.
I did it for the jokes, really.
But yes, we just got married.
And thank you for
the jaded applause.
That's really great.
Some of the guys are
going, oh, so she's taken.
OK.
That's why I stayed this long.
We can leave now and
turn around again.
But why, when I made that
video, when I made I am Indian--
this guy's laughing.
See, it's true, right?
So there's something to
that, I guess, hopefully.
So the reason I made the video--
why did I make I am Indian?
What was the way in?
I was sick and tired of
calling myself South Asian.
I just got tired of it.
I know it's inclusive.
I know it connects
into race better
to say South Asian
than to say Indian.
But I really meant what
I said in the video.
There's 1.3 billion of us.
We don't need a
cardinal direction.
Don't call us East Indian.
OK?
We're Indian.
That's it.
It's not our fault
Christopher Columbus got lost.
That's why I said that line.
And it really bothered me.
It really irked me.
And I felt that as long as
we kept saying South Asian,
we were going to lose
"Indian" as a word.
People just aren't going to
say it anymore in this country.
And I thought, that's not OK.
And I got tired at--
that one that really
pissed me off was Asian Indian.
I actually wrote a couple
of State Farm commercials
and Omi Vaidya was
the star of those.
And I realized that--
not that ad agency,
but they were telling us that
agencies, a lot of the time,
will have people check a box.
And they refer to us as
the Asian Indian market.
And I was just thinking,
where do you think India is.
It is in Asia.
You're just saying it twice.
I'm not a male man, right?
I'm sort of dressed like
one, I guess you could say.
But I should say man
male, the other way.
But no, we don't
have to say it twice
and just get more general or
something like that, you know?
So I knew there was
something there.
That was incongruent to me.
There was something about
saying South Asian and East
Indian that really bothered me.
And that what we do is we write
the jokes around the facts.
We don't write
facts around jokes.
We don't try to
find stuff like that
and write jokes
around it, because you
stay in "sillyville."
If you really want to say
something, we don't go,
what's funny about this, we
say, what are we making fun of.
Who's the victim?
What are we really
trying to poke fun at?
And in this particular video,
I was making fun of ignorance.
That was a big thing.
And then I already explained
the versus the feathers,
dots versus feathers.
So a lot of people
I know-- I wanted
to use one of the Golden State
Warriors since I'm up here,
but we couldn't find
any unrestricted images
of Steph Curry.
But this specific one was--
and it's an alley-oop, right?
That's kind of what
a joke is as well.
It's the setup and the punch.
And a lot of times, we'll have
a miscommunication in life
when you're trying
to speak to somebody.
And you'll tell
something and somebody
will just completely miss it.
Right?
We've all sent e-mails,
we got no response.
Right?
You sent it to 50 people.
Oh my gosh, I can't
wait to check my inbox.
No one wrote back, right?
And a lot of the time,
it was because the person
missed the setup.
They just didn't get the context
of what you were trying to say.
And so if this ball
is an errant toss
and it goes away
from the player,
he's not going to
able to slam it.
Right?
You need to set it up properly
and then you get the punch.
Then you get the impact.
There's actually a
third part to jokes.
So there's the setup,
the punch line,
and I'll tell you a little
thing that a lot of people who
are not stand-ups don't know.
There's a third part
to a joke called a tag.
And there's a four
part called walk out
when they leave the room.
A third part called
the tag-- it's usually
further explanation
or an act out.
You'll see a lot of
comedians say a line
and then they'll act it
out, or do an accent,
or something like that.
A great example is Seinfeld
has a bit about laundry.
And he talks about
washing laundry.
And his joke is,
now they show you
how detergents take
out bloodstains,
a pretty violent image there.
I think if you got a t-shirt
with a bloodstain all over it,
maybe laundry isn't
your biggest problem.
Maybe you should get rid of the
body before you do the wash.
Right?
So that's a beautiful joke, as
you can tell by the laughter.
The set up is, now
they show you how
detergents take out bloodstains,
a pretty violent image there.
The punch line is,
I think, if you've
got a t-shirt with blood
stains all over it,
maybe laundry isn't
your biggest problem.
And then after the
laugh, he tags it again--
and this is why he's
one of the greatest--
maybe you should get rid of the
body before you do the wash.
That's the tag.
And he even has another
tag where he says,
maybe you should try getting
the harpoon out of your chest
first.
Right?
So again, right,
it's another laugh.
It's another way of keeping
and getting these things.
This is where it gets
interesting, finally.
I used to work, like I
said, at Procter and Gamble.
This is the structure of every
commercial you've ever seen.
We-- I still say we-- we
were the world's largest--
we're still the world's
largest-- advertiser.
I just don't work
there anymore--
but world's largest advertiser
making a lot of commercials.
And every commercial you've seen
is structured just like a joke.
It's structured as an insight,
a benefit, and a reason
to believe.
Every ad is like that.
It doesn't have to go,
necessarily in that order.
But now, when you
watch commercials,
you will see-- you'll
start to notice this.
Insight is also known as
an accepted consumer belief
and it gets us all on
the same page-- something
like, no guy likes
the irritation that
comes with shaving.
Right?
And then all of the guys are
sort of nodding our heads
and going that's right,
unless you're you
and you don't shave very well--
very often-- I should say,
not very well, very often.
Really looking scruffy there.
So but no, we don't
like the irritation
that comes with shaving.
The benefit would be, the
new Gillette Fusion razor
provides a close shave
without razor burn.
Right?
So now guys go, cool, OK,
so that's the benefit.
And the reason to
believe could be
that's because Gillette has
added an 89th blade to it's
eludium pew 36 explosive
space modulator
or whatever the blades now have.
There are so many blades.
But I think that's what's
really interesting, is
that jokes and ads have
the same structure.
You know, a joke is a
setup, punch, and a tag.
And an ad is an insite,
benefit, and reason to believe.
So a lot of people, after I
made that video, a lot of people
said, oh, I liked your
commercial, which I thought
was really interesting.
I thought, well, it wasn't
really a commercial.
But I get, now, why people
say that it was a commercial.
It's just like when, in
India, when we go to India--
I did a tour there-- I've
done a few tours there--
it's really funny,
because Indians in India
have a different
way of explaining
that they like your videos.
You know, here, people will
come up to me and they'll say,
oh, I saw your YouTube video.
I liked your-- there, in India.
They they're so
sweet-- they say,
you know, I saw your youtubes.
I love your youtubes,
Jar, I love your youtubes.
It just sounds very
personal, you know,
like you've seen my tubes.
I don't have any tubes.
I mean, I'm post-med,
I realize that,
but I don't have any tubes.
Folks, I'm going to stop there,
because even though I have more
things to say, I want
to probably leave
a little bit of time
for Q&A. And if there
are any other main things
that I wanted to say,
we're going to do a Q&A here.
And then I think we'll take
some questions from the audience
as well.
But just so I can
wrap it up, I could
say that the second thing was
making an emotional connection.
So the first thing
was using humor.
The second thing was making
an emotional connection, which
I think that that video did.
And a lot of people felt
that it came from my soul.
And I think that's
an important thing,
is when we write things
and convey things
that we aspire with our head
and we pine with our hearts.
We crave with our bodies, right,
but we yearn with our souls.
And so if you want to make
something that really--N I
don't know when I turn
into Deepak Chopra,
but the idea is-- I even
had a slide for that.
That's too bad.
I had a slide with me and
Deepak Chopra, but oh well.
I don't know how many
of these other slides
I really wanted to show
you, but that's OK.
There were more, but
why don't we stop there,
just in the interest of time?
And we'll go ahead and we'll
do the Q&A. OK, thanks.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
There's me as Ghandi.
I at least got to show you that.
So that's me as Ghandi.
OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: So
you told us that you
did a lot of TV commercials.
Is there any favorites?
And do you want to
tell us a story about
how you [INAUDIBLE]?
RAJIV SATYAL: I think
the ones that we
wrote for-- so a friend
of mine and I in LA,
we co-wrote a couple of
State Farm commercials.
And they were played
by Omi Vaidya.
He was-- Vaidya, he
was the actor in them.
And again, one of
them was called--
it was an Indian wedding.
And it rains, you know?
And they have to somehow
all jump in a car.
And they're just wondering
if they have insurance
and that sort of thing.
So I think just the spectacle
of a huge Indian wedding
was kind of a cool thing to do.
So I think that's what's
really great about this job is
that you are always looking for
how you can express your jokes.
And that was actually
another point
that-- I'll just go
to my talking points
like I'm Marco Rubio.
But you know, Barack Obama
knew exactly what he was doing.
I'll just keep saying that.
But that's the idea.
As a commercial, we were
always trying to reach people
and saying where
are they receptive.
Should it be a TV ad?
Should be a billboard?
Should it be an internet pop-up?
Please God, no.
And jokes are the same
way, right, where you go,
does this work as a tweet.
Does it work as an
Instagram picture?
Does it work on stage?
Is it a sketch or
is it a commercial?
So I think part of
being a comedian
is being able to tell jokes
in a wide variety of media.
And so a lot of people
ask me that-- so,
how do you go over in India?
And I think it works,
I think, largely,
because I try to talk about
our-- there's an old quote that
says we bond according
to our similarities
and we grow according to our
differences, which I think
is beautiful and I love that.
But I think that
a lot of comedy is
about bringing people together.
What do we all do together?
And I find that stuff
to be a lot more
fun than the stuff that
sort of divides us apart
and go, well, I disagree with
this or disagree with that.
So I think, in that way, being
able to write commercials
is kind of cool, because
you get to express something
in a visual medium.
FEMALE SPEAKER: How did
you get into comedy?
Like saying you were a
materials engineer, then
you worked with
P&G as a marketer--
what was your in into comedy?
RAJIV SATYAL: I volunteered
at a tennis tournament,
because I'm Indian.
And you have to do something
with tennis, right?
It has to-- in this
country, especially.
It's cricket in India.
But here, the Indians who
couldn't play football,
we basically had to do
something with tennis.
And so I worked in
the player locker room
in Cincinnati, which is one
of the-- there are the four
grand slams in
tennis-- I don't know
how much everyone knows about
tennis-- the four grand slams.
And then it's the third
largest tournament after that.
So it's one of the biggest
tournaments in the world.
And I was working in the locker
room, got to see the players--
a little bit too
much of the players.
And I actually was
going to go on stage
for the very first time.
But then I ended up talking to
Pete Sampras, who, at the time,
was the world's
number one player.
And I did my stand-up
act for Pete Sampras.
That was the first time I'm
ever did stand-up comedy.
It was just for
him, and his doctor,
and a trainer, and my
supervisor, and one other guy.
And I did stand-up for him.
And it was really this
mind-blowing experience.
And it went kind
of not that well.
Gut it gave me the
confidence of going with it.
I had pictures
and posters of him
all over my room,
him and Andre Agassi.
And to me, to be able to
do that and get through it
gave me a lot of confidence
to say, OK, let me go up
and enter this
contest in Cincinnati,
which is where I'm from.
And I entered a contest.
I made the semifinals and
the next year, I won it.
So I sort of had this
knack to be able to do it.
But I wasn't really sure I
wanted to do it for a job.
Because I think, being Indian
was a real sort of-- you
kind of go, well, that's not--
you have to be an engineer.
You have to be a doctor.
You can't go do that as a job.
And that's not a
real thing, you know?
And even when I would
go to comedy clubs,
I would never look
at the guys and go,
I'm going to be that guy.
I never thought that that
would be something I would do.
So the fact that
I do it full time
is still kind of a
mind-blowing thing.
I'm surprised that I get
not paid to come here.
Next question.
I'm not bitter.
Not bitter.
FEMALE SPEAKER: To
give others context,
Rajiv also hosts shows or,
like, motivation sessions
with corporations
and NFL players.
What's people's
reactions when they
say-- when the
company tells them,
hey, a comedian is
here to motivate
you guys to do your job better?
RAJIV SATYAL: I think
people, at first,
are kind of going, well, what's
a comedian go to tell us.
I think that's a
natural sort of thing.
But I think it's funny
that you bring up
the NFL, because performing
for football players
was an interesting experience.
And I actually had to do
a three-hour-- some of you
are going, well, I can't even
take this guy for an hour--
a three-hour session
on personal branding.
And it was all about
life after the NFL.
And these were rookies.
These were players who were--
first of all, you have a 1
in 16,000 chance
of making the NFL.
And that's if you played
high school football,
not you, not me.
I don't-- it's way-- it's
like Powerball numbers for US.
OK?
But for these guys
who actually have
the speed, and the
strength, and all
that-- I don't know why
I picked on you for that.
But anyway, point being that--
I don't want to play in the NFL.
I'd rather be
[INAUDIBLE] or something.
But it's a very
difficult thing and so
it's not a receptive
audience at all.
I mean, these guys
just got to the NFL.
They're all pumped up.
Let me talk about
life after football,
after you don't make it.
Right?
I mean, what is that?
It could be not a more hostile
audience, you could imagine.
It's a three-hour
mandatory session.
They don't necessarily
want to be there.
And at the time, I was 32.
And I was a 32-year-old
scrawny Indian nerd
talking to 22-year-old
black and white jocks.
You know, just football players,
guys who could good just mash--
you know, stuff guys like me
into a locker kind of thing,
right?
And I won them over.
Because I was trying to talk
and they're just stone-faced,
just nothing.
Just when do we--
that kind of thing.
I just tried to talk
to one of the guys.
And I just said, so
what do you do, man?
I just go out to clubs
and stuff, you know.
And I said, do you dance?
He goes, no, I don't dance.
I go, you just
roll up your pants
and do the Rockaway, which
was a line from a hip hop song
that was popular at the time.
And he goes, oh, OK, OK.
And then I got him, right?
So there was something I had
to say that I had to go to him
to say, I speak your
language, right?
It's the same thing
wherever you perform,
whether it's the Middle East,
or India, or it's Alabama.
You have to say something.
I mean, I got out
in front of Alabama,
400 white and
black people, maybe
10 black people,
390 white people.
No brown people
anywhere to be found.
Alabama-- I mean,
not even Birmingham,
but outside of Birmingham.
And I got up there and I
went out there and I just,
in an Indian accent
I said, roll tide.
And they went nuts,
right, because they
love the Alabama Crimson Tide.
They went crazy.
Oh my god, this guy knows.
Right?
So you need to say something
specific that will get people.
I do a joke about how
I was trying to-- I
was on shoddy.com.
It's not really shoddy,
it's shoddy-- S-H-O-D-D-Y--
shoddy.com.
Or shady.com, right?
And so I was on that.
And it asked all these questions
and it asked if I was a manglik
And I didn't know what
a manglik was, you know?
So I looked it up online.
And I always did
a joke about how
I felt bad looking
up my culture online.
But so many Indians
work at Google,
it's like asking your uncle.
Right?
So it was this big
thing, a big laugh
line that works everywhere
but at Google, apparently.
OK, great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
I will open up the
house for some questions
before I go and rant on.
Anybody has any questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: You talked about
having a knack for this thing.
Do you think people
can learn this?
RAJIV SATYAL: Can
people learn this?
So it's sort of the
age old question of,
is it innate, right?
Is it congenital
or is it-- that's
not a bad word-- congenital--
or is it born leaders?
People always have
the same question.
I think-- I just read a
book called "On Writing"
by Stephen King.
And it's a great book, even
if you're not into writing,
because he breaks things
down so specifically.
He tells you, hey, this
work-- it's different things
for different people.
But you look at his
bio and it says,
Stephen King has written
50 books, all of them
worldwide bestsellers.
OK, I'm going to listen
to this guy, right?
Because I've been
telling somebody,
he goes, well,
that works for him.
I go, you haven't even
published anything.
Yes, that works
for Stephen King.
I think I'm going to read this.
And he talks about where he puts
his desk, how many hours a day
to write, how many words.
He really breaks it down.
But he basically gives you four
categories of bad, competent,
good, and great.
And he says people
like Ernest Hemingway--
great, just great,
just touched by God.
There's nothing
that you can-- he
doesn't have to read this book.
And then there are
people who are just bad.
They're just bad.
You know?
Because I get people
asking me that question.
They go, how do I get better.
And I watch their first
time on stage and I go,
I was never that bad.
I'm sorry, I was
just never that bad.
I mean, I watch my first set
and I go, that's pretty good.
Right?
I had some game.
I had some chops.
But what he talks about is,
if you're bad, you're bad.
If you're great, you're great.
But the book is supposed to
take you from competent to good.
And he calls himself good.
Right?
So he's Hemingway--
so I would say,
Chris Rock, George
Carlin, Dave Chappelle,
these guys are great.
Then you have the bad people
who are bad, who, you know,
we've seen them.
Then you've got people
who are competent.
And then you're
trying to get good.
I would call myself
competent and I would
say I'm trying to get good.
But to say I'm
going to be great,
that's sort of,
wow, that's amazing.
You're going to great?
I mean, how many people
could come to Google
and go, I'm going to be Sundar?
I'm going to be Sundar Pichai.
I mean, you're going to.
Then they take
entrepreneurial classes.
I don't think
entrepreneurs have to take
entrepreneurial
classes, you just
know how to start a company.
Sorry.
But yeah, I think it's
a similar kind of thing,
that I think a lot of it--
it's similar to dancing.
With dancing, you
have to have rhythm.
But you don't have
to have rhythm.
If you can count, you
don't have to have rhythm.
So if you can get on the
dance floor and you can count,
you can bypass rhythm.
Timing is the same
thing as comedy.
You can learn to tell jokes,
but you'll never have timing,
and so you won't be great.
But you might be good.
OK.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Any
other questions?
RAJIV SATYAL: If you've got to
leave, I totally understand.
I don't want to hold anyone.
I know people have
meetings and stuff.
AUDIENCE: It's
obviously awesome to see
so many Indian American
comics emerge on the scene.
So there's tons of
material for Americans,
tons of material for Indians.
And you put both
of them together,
it's like a nuclear reaction.
You have 10 times the material.
All that is awesome,
but do you see a time
when the Indian Americans
grow past their ethnic roots
and do secular comedy?
And when you see
an Indian American,
the first thing you
imagine is they're going
to tap their ethnic roots.
Do you see that going
past their roots
and just do awesome comedy
like Seinfeld or something?
RAJIV SATYAL: Sort
of Asian fusion?
Sort of the fission
kind of thing.
I always think that Indian
Americans, specifically,
are very good comedians.
A lot of that is because we are
products of the world's largest
democracy and the world's
most powerful democracy.
So we're sort of
free speech squared.
Right?
I mean, we're raised
to have free speech
and it's just
amplified, right, which
is why I think if
you look at some
of the Indian American
actors, they're OK.
I think they're OK.
But I think the Indian American
comedians are really strong.
And I think you're seeing
that with Aziz Ansari.
I think Aziz Ansari
doesn't necessarily
do a lot of ethnic humor.
And when I say American, I kind
of include Russell in that.
He's Canadian, but it's the
51st through 55th state,
so whatever.
It's 30 million people.
Come on, it's not a country.
So the point is,
it's not America.
It's certainly not India.
But I think that there's
the idea that, yes,
I think you're seeing that.
I think you're seeing
people who do mine it.
I think that, hopefully,
I try to walk that line.
I try to do stuff that, I
think, appeals to everyone.
But there's that sweet
spot of targeting
of saying, if you're Indian,
you probably maybe get
it a little bit more.
But I don't think, any
more, people feel that.
The first two
years I did comedy,
I didn't do any Indian
jokes at all-- none.
And so I don't think
it's necessary.
But I think we can support
Indian American comedians
and I really appreciate the
support today and everybody
coming out.
Because this is how we do
it to quote Montell Jordan.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I would
put in one of my questions.
So you said that you
guys just got married.
Thank you for coming
here today, Harsha.
And I know that
there's a funny story
behind how you proposed to her.
Do you want to tell
that story to everyone?
RAJIV SATYAL: Or do you?
The way you said it I though
maybe you wanted to tell it,
so I thought, OK, fine.
Well, I proposed to Harsha on
stage, which was kind of cool.
We were-- I was performing
at the Cincinnati Funny Bone.
And I was opening
for Kevin Nealon,
who you might know from
"Saturday Night Live"
or from "Weeds."
And I proposed to Harsha.
There's actually a
YouTube video of it,
so you can Google it or
YouTube it, and look it up,
and see that proposal,
which is pretty cool.
And then I did that in
front of Kevin Nealon.
And then we had Russell
Peters perform at our wedding.
So that was pretty sweet.
That was a great comedic
arc to the whole thing.
And since I had to be
the last one to speak,
I could say Russell
Peters has opened for me,
so that was the whole idea.
But we got married--
Harsha is from Austin,
so we got married in Texas.
And we had a full-on
cowboys and Indians wedding,
because it was kind of great.
Because we're Indians,
but I'm a cowboy.
I'm Hindu.
I worship cows.
So I really am a cowboy.
FEMALE SPEAKER: OK.
We have time for one more
question from the audience.
RAJIV SATYAL: We exhausted it.
It's like popcorn
that stopping popping.
Rania.
AUDIENCE: So in terms
of asking-- sorry,
in terms of making jokes that,
sometimes, can offend people,
I'm just curious about
any time that, maybe, you
have made a joke that crossed
the line, how you recovered.
RAJIV SATYAL: I mean,
I've bombed many times.
I mean, every comedian has.
But I'm trying to
think if I've done
anything that was so over
the top that really offended
people.
I mean, I've definitely
had people come up to me
after shows and say, wow,
that was-- that one joke.
Actually, there was a
joke I did-- OK, yeah.
So I was in Chicago and I was
performing with Hari Kondabolu.
Hannibal Buress,
actually, was there.
Hannibal Buress
was our headliner.
It was all mostly
a Desi comedy show.
It was an Indian
comedy show, largely.
But we had Hannibal Buress
perform, actually, in Chicago.
And it was for a
women's shelter.
OK?
So I did one of my jokes that
I do that usually goes over
really well.
And it didn't in the
beginning, because it
had a certain-- I
did the joke where
I go, we all have a number
on a scale from one to 10.
And I'm a 6, and I know
that, and that's fine.
And she's looking at me
like, dude, you're a four.
But seriously, the idea
is-- the thing is--
and I'm Indian, so I've
come up with a formula.
And the formula is,
you can only date
and be happy with somebody
who's up or down one
digit from you on the scale.
OK?
That's-- really, it is.
So if you're a six, you can
be happy with a five, six,
or seven.
Don't act.
Ask how this happened.
I don't know.
But that's the rule, right?
So you can date a
five, six, or seven.
But I married a 10.
So at the time, I was single.
And so I said, but
I've dated tens before.
And people go,
well, how is that.
Well, the thing is, women,
you are what you are.
I go, you know, if you're
an eight, you're an eight.
You're beautiful.
But you can't go up
or down on the scale.
We live in a chauvinist society.
But fellas can go up on
the scale if we're funny
and we have money.
So I'm a six for looks.
I'm funny on most nights.
I become a seven.
I've got some money in the
bank so i become an eight.
And that's how I date tens.
And I know some people are
looking at me, like, yeah,
but that's still
two numbers apart.
Right?
What I do is I meet at 10 and
I break her self-esteem down
so she thinks she's a nine.
Right?
It's funny.
See?
Everybody's laughing.
But the room, being a battered
women's shelter kind of
went-- you know, one
of those moments.
And Hari comes back to me
backstage and just goes,
dude, telling that
joke at this place.
I go, I know.
And I had a couple women come up
to me and say, come on, really.
I said, yeah, it's funny.
I mean, sorry, that's
a funny joke, OK?
It's just funny.
But yeah, I think
that was definitely
not knowing your audience.
And I didn't get to that
part of the presentation,
but I do a whole thing
about knowing your audience.